the Joe Rogan experience that's the
house I bought to write my first book it
was unbelievably I was so I could focus
for like 14 hours a day 16 hours a day
writing but the reason I was able to
focus so well was because of cigarettes
I'd write for about 28 29 minutes total
focus go outside smoke the nicotine
which is reset all the focus it was an
unbelievable drug but it's a terrible
delivery system I've heard someone
recently say I recently heard a kind of
reluctant Trump supporter say the same
thing about Trump that a lot of the
things he's doing policy-wise especially
foreign policy her economic policy
really they like it so they say he's
like he's like a cigarette like the drug
is good the delivery system is
absolutely terrible now how is the
vaping did you switch with never but no
I quit smoking a long time ago although
I quit you know it's interesting I wrote
in my first book my family memoir about
the Jewish Catholic family I wrote in
there not that I was a smoker but that
there's one instance where I stepped
outside with my brother after this
intense moment and we had a cigarette
and a few years later the book had been
published I was buying for the first I
was now newly married and I know that
you're supposed to buy life insurance
and so I got this insurance broker and
he knew my name he said I read your book
I said oh that's that's great glad to
hear and then we started to price out
the insurance and he said you know what
do you do are you a smoker I said no not
a smoker cuz I'd quit a few years
earlier and then he called me back and
he said you know I read your book where
you stepped outside to have a cigarette
with your brother all of a sudden I got
the smoking rate for life insurance even
though you quit yeah even though I quit
because you used to smoke yeah oh yeah
oh you smoked at all well that's not
what I thought he asked me to are you a
smoker I said no because I'd quit but
anyway Dave there's no like
scientifically like this there's a
certain time window when your lungs are
fully recovered they also say so so this
message I would say is really serious
for anybody even if you've been smoking
40 years they say if you quit your lungs
can actually recover greatly so it's
worth it yeah smoking is
I hate to say it I think smoking is a
terrible idea it's a terrible idea
there's no if answer on the other hand
this vaping replaced the feet like Adam
curry switched to vaping yeah this crazy
contraption one of those guys is in
there really complicated you know Garage
remote control looking vamping things
that he's into those things and you know
he quit and that's how he quit so the
best science at the moment says that
vaping is almost certainly much better
than smoking yeah because they don't
know all the chemicals and all the
damage potential damage that vaping may
or may not do but they do know the
damage is cigarette combust combustible
cigarettes and all the chemicals there
are demonstrably pretty bad yeah so even
though like you said we were told
doctors do it this is the best we were
told the same thing about sugar sugar
gives you a great boost and so on it's
awful but again my take is if you want
to smoke go ahead well but wait a minute
live in a finite life oh wait a minute
let's say now we are talking about who
pays right so this is gets back to the
externality thing if you smoke and I'm
paying for your health insurance as the
tax payer don't I get to have a say it's
a very good question and how far should
we extend that because if you're fat
should I have to pay right you keep
eating why do you keep eating right okay
if you if you don't sleep well and you
prone to heart attacks so am I supposed
to pay right now you sleep more you know
there's there's so many variables are
you a guy who rock climbs well what if
you fall and break your leg I have to
[ __ ] pay for that there's a lot of
variables so you got to wonder about
when you you start breaking down how
much how much assistance people get
based on their life choices but the way
to do that is to is to price it and this
is where economists are really useful
you know even though they sit down for
the individual and punish them for their
behavior not punish them tax them
charging them right if I want to be a
rock climber and a smoker and and
everything but I get free free health
care then there should probably be a
premium or I should probably pay into a
little fund that is a free if there's a
premium well it's never look health care
is not never free right not in this but
no no no even in Scandinavia it's not
for its free to the user at point of
purchase yes but no it's expensive and
that's what's hard nav has done well
we're talking about the user that right
we're talking about the user having to
pay
Premium but you're right you're already
paying your taxes let's say you're
paying 20% total tax whatever that goes
into the healthcare but then
additionally right you theoretically
know this can be very hard to regulate
behavior because again where do we draw
the line it would about BMX riding what
about people who do this and that
there's a lot of things if a silly thing
you do you have to pay for yeah there's
a there's so many things that people do
that we take for granted how about
little girls do gymnastics
well how much the parents have to pay
how about driving in a car yes one of
the scariest right
how about so many things we should just
all sit inside with helmets and watch
YouTube about CrossFit how much you got
to pay you want to do CrossFit you know
well then then we got to measure the
benefit to CrossFit right you're
building up your body you're gonna live
longer well that's positive and you're
also probably hanging out with lunatics
like you who are riding you know crazy
vehicles right so I'm a kind driver but
I think that CrossFit the benefit yeah
is you're getting in shape so that
balances itself out as long as you do it
intelligently you're you're involved in
athletics but should we reward people
should they pay less so if someone does
yoga three days a week we're supposed to
make them pay less I mean I think you
get into some weird swampy area and
people start the system the same way
when you know people got paid for rats
they let rats loose and then [ __ ]
kill them because people are gross yeah
but we're improving again as a species
yeah let's not lose sight of that
[Applause]